le commissaire fédéral à l'environnement
et au développement durable jerry de
marco affirme que le ministère des
ressources naturelles à ottawa à
surestimer le potentiel de l'hydrogène
pour réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre des hypothèses
surréaliste aurait été utilisé notamment
en ce qui concerne l'évolution du prix
de l'électricité des politiques
publiques et l'adoption de nouvelles
technologies avec nous ce soir jouanno
est mort qui est chercheur principal à
la chaire de gestion du secteur de
l'énergie à hec montréal bonsoir
bonsoir le commissaire dit qu'on est
trop ambitieux 1 par rapport à la place
qu'occupera vraiment l'hydrogène dans
l'avenir qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
conclusion du commissaire à
l'environnement
là c'est pas seulement le concert c'est
aussi le groupe intergouvernemental
d'experts en qui m'a démontré que pour
la meilleure des circonstances confuses
justement les modèles qu'on compare
l'hydrogène avec toutes les options pour
la décarbonation ces deux mille cinq ans
dans merde et qu'on aurait à peu près 2
% du bilan énergétique mondiale qui
serait attribuée à l'hydrogène au québec
on a aussi eu des études semblables qui
ont été faites pour la ministère de
l'environnement et dans le meilleur
décor encore d'ici 2050 on parle de 3 %
du bilan qui serait représenté par
l'hydrogène donc c'est une énergie
complémentaire il faut le faire parce
qu'il ya des secteurs qui sont
difficiles à décarbonés mais ça va pas
être alors que toute la décarbonation
est d'ailleurs madame whitmore avec
d'autres chercheurs vous l'écriviez
récemment dans un texte publié dans la
presse vous disiez que l'engouement
qu'on sent l'engouement politique et
médiatique paraît démesuré avez vous
écrit et qu'un appel à la réalité
s'impose dites nous pourquoi cet appel à
la réalité
parce qu on veut pas que ça devienne une
distraction pour ce qu'on a vraiment
besoin de faire puis ultime ans le
groupe ça c'est pas juste les chercheurs
qu'ils montent mais aussi encore une
fois le giec est donc études savez
comment on consomme ultime ans on va
voir on déploie des mesures d'économie
circulaire stade il faut qu'on travaille
et quand tu consommes temps les
ressources que l'énergie à l'intérieur
d'un monde qui physiquement limité et
donc sa musique faut qu'on soit beaucoup
plus optimale qu'on réduise nos pertes
comme qu'on puisse valoriser ce qu'on
consomme déjà qu'on consomme beaucoup
mieux pour avoir usé de moyens pour
créer de la richesse qui compensa des
nouvelles énergies comme l'hydrogène
saluer un peu tendance à faire en sorte
qu'on peut avoir l'impression de
continuer à consommer comme qu'on le
faisait depuis toujours quand que la
réalité de l'alliance avait très
différents est-ce qu'on a une idée
réaliste quand même des besoins qu'on
pourrait avoir en hydrogène citrap 6 30
ans d'ici 50 ans
en fait l'hydrogène ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que ça permet quand
même de faire
c'est une énergie quand même assez
puissant dans les secteurs industriels
où c'est difficile à décarbonée on peut
pas tout électrifié qu'on compense par
exemple dans le secteur maritime dans le
secteur de l'aviation donc c'est là
qu'est ce qu'on appelle des secteurs
sans regret qu'on peut miser dessus
parce que l'hydrogène ça coûte très cher
salle une chaîne de valeur extrêmement
complexe dépendant de quelles sources
qu'on utilise pour la produire parce que
si on peut comme elle électrice et on
peut utiliser du charbon du gaz naturel
l'électricité plusieurs différentes
sources même des sous produits chimiques
pour produire l'hydrogène actuellement
95% l'hydrogène s'est faite à base de
combustible fossile est donc le grand
défi c'est de voir son pouvoir faire une
hydre orientale juste pour remplacer
déjà les utilisations qu'on fait sur les
marchés par exemple pour la production
de denrées ou dans certains secteurs
clés industriels est ce qu'on peut déjà
remplacé cet hydrogène noix ou gris
qu'on appelle par hydrogène d'air c'est
un défi en soi et ensuite dans ces
secteurs dont je mentionnais qui extrait
sans regrets comme dans certains
secteurs industriels l'aviation ou marty
sans regrets comme vous dites donc
autrement dit où ça vaut ça vaut la
peine de le faire mais est ce
pardon où ça va être rentable aussi
davantage et dans les secteurs où la
conversion aux énergies renouvelables
par exemple est bien entamée on pense
aux voitures de plus en plus le véhicule
électrique est ce que l'hydrogène encore
un rôle à jouer
pour le secteur du transport personnel
de plus en plus les dynamiques de marché
montrent clairement le les voitures à
batteries se démarque en termes de
rentabilité en termes de flexibilité et
tout ça ça laisse quand même un grand
défi c'est quand même un peu près 6 % au
grand meilleur des cocus des véhicules à
batteries représentent dans le marché
québécois par exemple mais l'hydrogène
sera encore plus petits si on en a
acheté 50 au québec puis ça ça s'appelle
un volet mélo ça peut être utile c'est
peut-être éventuellement dans le
transport de marchandises lourd mais
encore une fois ses yeux plusieurs
technologies ya rien qui se démarque en
raison des coûts c'est très très cher
pas juste la production d'hydrogène ou
aussi les camions eux mêmes et à la fin
ce qui est important c'est pas juste la
production d'hydrogène mais ce qu'est ce
que ça représente pour les utilisateurs
finaux et donc on pensait on parle
jamais de sow qui va être important
parce que si on a déjà des problèmes
quand le prix de l'essence augmente de
quelques scènes mais je n'ai vous quand
m en 10 achetés dj's pour un nouveau
véhicule ça va faire on va faire encore
plus sensible donc ce que vous dites
dans le format d'amorcer soyons prudents
oui l'hydrogène fait partie de la liste
des solutions mais il ne faut pas
exagérer l'apport de l'hydrogène pour
l'économie et pour la réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
oui ben en fait si on est pour mettre
beaucoup des fonds publics pour
développer cette filière là le
gouvernement à l'intérêt un intérêt
pardon à le développer d'une façon
responsable et aussi d'une façon qui
veut faire en sorte que les fonds
publics vont maximiser l'objectif qu'on
recherche qui est décarbonée on a
beaucoup d'autres investissements en
enfer en trop dans la réduction de la
consommation d'énergie et ensuite
l'électrification voit donc les
biocarburants l'hydrogène c'est
important mais il faut le faire de façon
responsable
merci beaucoup madame où est mort
c'était très intéressant et très
pertinent merci et à la prochaine pour
voir nos émissions entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne i see her dit
[Musique]